Zurück nach Singapur in den urbanen Dschungel,
der durchaus nicht nur aus Beton besteht.
Hier tragen auch die Hochhäuser mit
ihrer Bepflanzung zu einem besseren
Stadtklima bei und liefern damit ein
Beispiel für nachhaltiges Bauen.
Morgens um 6 Uhr unterwegs mit den ETH
Forschern des Future Cities Lab
Wir besuchen eine Überbauung namens Sky Ville, Heim für 3000 Menschen, erbaut 2015.
Auf verschiedenen Stockwerken befinden sich Gärten.
Dieser hier auf dem achten Stock ist eine Oase für Vögel.
Der Biologe Richard Belcher hat ihr vorkommen untersucht.
Wir fanden heraus,
dass solche Dachgärten einen positiven
Effekt auf das vorkommen einheimischer
Vogelarten haben. Bei den eingewanderten
Arten gab es keinen Unterschied.
Doch wichtig sind für die Artenvielfalt die einheimischen Arten, für die diese
Dachgärten tatsächlich Zufluchtsorte geworden sind.
Von den Grünflächen profitieren längst nicht nur die Vögel.
Sie erfüllen auch andere wichtige Funktionen.
Die Grünflächen sind Aufenthaltsorte für
Menschen. Bäume spenden Schatten und
sorgen für Kühlung.
Das ist eine der wichtigsten Funktionen
der städtischen Grünflächen. Sie kühen
die Stadt im Gegensatz zu den Gebäuden
die im Beton die Hitze speichern und sie
dann während der kühlen Nacht an die Umgebung abgeben.
Man nennt das Phänomen auch den Hitze Insel-Effekt.
Städte heizen sich stark auf, weil die Gebäude Hitze abstrahlen.
Eine Hitze, die paradoxerweise auch von
den zahlreichen Klimaanlagen mitproduziert wird
Begrünung als natürliches Kühlmittel.
Das Hotel Oasia Downton
für den diesjährigen internationalen
Hochhaus-Preis nominiert, ist ein
Paradebeispiel für Nachhaltigkeit.
Die grossen Innenhöfe sorgen für natürliche Belüftung.
Wasser überall. Auch dies hat einen kühlenden Effekt.
Zudem entstehen stimmungsvolle Gemeinschaftszonen
21 verschiedene Schlingpflanzen wachsen an der Fassade
Für die Vögel Futter und Lebensraum.
Die Artenvielfalt hat in dieser Stadtgegend markant zugenommen.
Ein immenser Aufwand wird in den Unterhalt gesteckt.
Doch dieser hohe Preis scheint sich zu lohnen.
Lohnt sich die Forschung die die ETH in
Singapur im Future Cities Lab betreibt, auch für die Schweiz?
Was kann die Schweiz von Singapur lernen?
Ganz vieles, ist sich Sascha Menz sicher.
Mir in der Schweiz, wir werden nicht weniger,
wir werden mehr. Wir stellen fest, dass sich auch bei uns das Klima verändert.
Wir hatten jetzt einen sehr warmen Sommer.
All die Effekte, welche von der Aussenwelt auf unser Wohnen,
auf unser Leben und Arbeiten mit hineinwirken,
die können wir von hier übernehmen
und wir können in dem Sinn lernen,
wie wir vielleicht auch in der Schweiz
unsere Gebäude neu planen und neu bauen werden.